You've probably seen all sorts of itemsflying around recently, and it can get a little confusing as to how they all relate toone another.
Machine learning, deep learning, foundation models. And you've probably seenother terms like generative AI and large language models.
So let's bring an end to theconfusion and put these terms in their place.
There's one thing they all have in common.
They are all terms related to the field of artificial intelligence or A.I.
Now A.I.refers to the simulation of human intelligence in machines enabling them to perform tasks that typically require human thinking.
Now and its various forms and paradigms hasbeen around for decades.
Perhaps you've heard of the chat bot called Eliza, thatwas developed in the mid 1960s, and that could mimic human like conversation, to an extent.
Now a subfield of A.I. is called machine learning, so this sits within the field of AI. Now what's machine learning?
Well, it focuses on developing algorithms that allow computers to learn from andmake decisions based upon data,
rather than being explicitly programed to perform a specific task.
These algorithms use statistical techniques to learn patterns in data and make predictionsor decisions without human intervention.
But like A.I. ML or machine learning is a verybroad term. It encompasses a range of techniques and approaches
from traditional statisticalmethods through to complex neural networks. Now, some of the core categories within ML we canthink of are firstly supervised learning,
where models are trained on labeled data. There's alsounsupervised learning,
and that's where the models find patterns in data without predefined labels. And there's also reinforcement learning.
And that's where models learn by interacting with anenvironment and receiving feedback.
Okay, so where does deep learning come in? Well, deeplearning is a subset of machine learning.
Goes right there. Now, that specifically focuses onartificial neural networks with multiple layers,
and we can think of them looking bit like this. So these are nodes and all of our connections.
Now, those layers where we get the deep partfrom. And while traditional ML techniques might be efficient for linear separationsor simpler patterns,
deep learning excels at handling vast amounts of unstructured datalike images or natural language
and discovering intricate structures within them.
Now, I do wantto point out that not all machine learning is deep learning. Traditional machine learning methodsstill play a pivotal role in many applications.
So we've got techniques like linear regression,that's a popular technique, or decision trees, or support vector machines, or clustering algorithms.
These are all other types of machine learning, and they've been widely used for a long time. In somescenarios, look, deep learning might be overkill
or it just isn't the most suitable approach. Okay,so machine learning, deep learning,
what else ah, yeah, foundation models. Okay, so wheredo foundation models fit into this?
Well, the term foundation model was popularized in 2021by researchers at the Stanford Institute
and it fits primarily within the realm of deep learning.So I'm going to put foundation models right here.
Now, these models are large scale neuralnetworks trained on vast amounts of data,and they serve as a base or a foundation for a multitude of applications.
So instead of training a model from scratch foreach specific task, you can take a Pre-trainedfoundation model and fine tune it fora particular application,
which saves a bunch of time and resources. Now, foundationmodels have been trained on diverse datasets,
capturing a broad range of knowledge and can beadapted to tasks ranging from language translationto content generation to image recognition.
So in the grand scheme of things foundation models, they sit within the deep learning categorybut represent a shift towards more generalized,
adaptable and scalable AI solutions.
So look,I think this is hopefully looking a bit clearer now. But there are some other A.I. relatedterms. I think it's worth also explaining.
And one of those is large language models or LLMs Now,
these are a specific type of foundation model, so I've put them in this box here,
and theyare centered around processing and generating humanlike text. So let's break it down, LLM.
The first L that's large, and that refers to the scale of the model. LLMs possess a vast numberof parameters, often in the billions or even more.
And this enormity is part of what gives LLMstheir nuanced understanding and capability.
Second, L that language that designed tounderstand and interact using human languages,
as they are trained on massive data sets. LLMs cangrasp grammar, context, idioms and even culturalreferences.
And the last letter and that's formodel at the core that computational models
a series of algorithms and parameters working
together to process input and produce output.
LLMs can handle a broad spectrum of languagetasks like answering questions, translating or even creative writing.
Now, if LLMs one exampleof foundation models, what are some others? Well, there's a bunch we can think of.
One of those isbeing vision models that can see in and in quotes, interpret and generate images. There arescientific models.
Give that an S and scientific models, for example, are used in biology wherethere are models for predicting how proteins fold into 3D shapes,
and there are audio modelsas well for generating human sounding speech or composing the next fake Drake hit song.
And finally, one last term that's gaining traction. We've all heardabout it. It's generative AI.
Now this term pertains to models and algorithmsspecifically crafted to generate new content.
Essentially, while foundation models providethe underlying structure and understanding,
generative AI is about harnessing that knowledgeto produce something that is new.
It's the creative expression that emerges from the vastknowledge base of these foundation models.
And with that, I think we've fully filledout a AI buzzword bingo scorecard.
And look, we have detailed videos on all of thesetopics. So check those out to learn more.